The class that defines a marker is
called the MarkerOptions class.
With this you have a number of
properties that you use to define your
map marker.
You can set its position using a LatLng,
and, of course, the LatLng
contains the latitude and longitude
where you want the marker to be.
And you can set its
title using a string.
As you saw earlier when I
had my rinks for example,
renton, all that was was
a string called renton.
And here is an example of building
a marker option that does that.
I say MarkerOptions renton equals
new MarkerOptions.position,
my latitude and longitude, I just pass
it a new LatLng, with the latitude and
longitude, and then the title("renton").
So this was the code that I used to
generate that pin on renton that you saw
in the application.
As you can see,
it's pretty straightforward.
And when you have a map,
you can add this to your map by calling
the ad marker method on your map.
Let's take a look at this in
action in Android Studio.